[Music]
we are back with our e3 2018 coverage
i'm joined by oscar dais hello Dave I
have been fighting zombies in days gone
and in real life maybe so I played about
half an hour of days gone I sweat over
two levels the first level was quite
stealth focus so I was essentially
tasked with retrieving a part for my
motorbike so I had to sneak into this
camp yeah I ride a motorbike what of it
so I'd sneak into this camp and avoid
all the zombies because it was quite a
lot of them around at this point I
didn't really have a lot of weapons I
had a shotgun and I had a pistol but
that was pretty much it and also I had a
like a bat
that wasn't very powerful at all I tried
to take out a few zombies and failed
miserably and so I snuck in I managed to
retrieve the part took out a couple of
zombies on the way collecting items
there's all sorts of rags and fuel and
stuff intellectuals yeah yeah exactly
that you can craft stuff with manage to
get the part and then at this point my
partner got sort of captured by bandits
so not actually zombies but you know
humans that had gone bad essentially and
there was this brutal cutscene where
they were actually burning his arm like
they really have like it was it was
quite horrible to see like they got a
blowtorch
I'm fully just set his arm on fire yeah
it wasn't it wasn't fun and so that was
the end of that mission and in terms of
like how it felt to play I actually
thought it felt quite rough like yeah
how does like had a stealth work at a
zombie scenario because if there's loads
of them it's gonna it's kind of weird to
imagine that you not get seen much at
this point there weren't so many of them
and there were enough buildings that you
could stay in cover and there were a
couple of hairy moments right to run
away and then I managed to lose them but
yeah it didn't feel particularly dynamic
it wasn't you know this isn't gonna be
Metal Gear Solid 5 levels of stealth
complexity is is very basic
stay hidden take them out if there's one
isolated that's pretty much it
the second level I played was a lot more
open it was like this huge sort of
valley with
hit in the middle that had like hundreds
of zombies swarming around just eating
on flesh I think I think it was like a
mass grave or something and with of a
raised hill area around it and so this
was essentially designed to showcase the
amount of zombies can be on screen at
one time and there were lots of them
there and this one was a lot more about
using your the tools at your disposal so
at this point I was a lot more geared up
by a head of an LMG I had a shotgun I
had loads of explosives
and so I had to go around and lay traps
there was like these oil tankers
scattered around the map as well so it's
all about laying the traps next the oil
tankers that was essentially what you
were pushed to do even though you could
technically do it in any way you wanted
but I tried doing it just winging it and
I died very quickly so I laid the few
traps then I got spotted they run after
me the traps explode the oil tankers
which takes out a few of the zombies but
again it I don't know it didn't quite it
didn't feel very impactful because like
you've got this huge oil tanker
explosion it takes out like three
zombies and it's like yeah and and even
when I was like shooting them with my
LMG like I'd periodically sort of turn
around and fire a few rounds my LMG at
them and you know you have hundreds of
zombies coming at you and you're firing
a few bullets and they go down in like
one hit and so it doesn't really feel
particularly satisfying because it just
feels even though there's hundreds of
them it still feels kind of easy that's
like that's that was a big concern like
one when we first sorties of the game I
think it was last year the biggest draw
was like there's a lot of zombies it
means you're gonna be killing them off
like a lot so it needs exactly it didn't
really feel that it's nice fun because
they go down so easy and the death
animation I don't know whether it's just
for this build maybe but they literally
just fall over and it's like there's
it's just hand off yeah it's like yeah
it's like off and it's like I don't know
it didn't really grab me and the
crafting was quite basic as well it was
simply a case of just picking up
everything you can find
and then you've got you've got like a
weapon wheel and you can like press r1
to craft a Molotov or craft a napalm
Molotov or craft a medikit or whatever
and it's like I don't know it just
seemed
very basic nothing there was really
grabbing me in the same with the combat
so at the moment days gone isn't really
grabbing me it looks fine
the framerate was a bit iffy especially
when there was loads of zombies coming
on-screen I don't know I I think it's
got a lot of promise but I think it's
gonna need some work between here and
and launch alright well we'll definitely
keep an eye on on Days gone but for
everything else 2018 III make sure you
subscribe to games for calm